foreign
not
hmm
it's not turned
it doesn't matter which side you want to
go to because the spiral can be
generated from this angle
spiral can be generated through this
thing
you are going to yield
how far do you yield when he hits zero
okay so he hits zero
foreign
spiral on the inside so you're not going
here
you have to reconcile
this one this way
[Music]
different
thanks
not too young
foreign
so this this pattern is uh key
this pattern this pattern
this this is the fight is is firing
okay
it doesn't bother those things you share
right and I'm spirally
you see how I did that same time okay
so that's why I don't I don't really
care if you do it with multiple steps
we don't
you don't have to be you know Mr Kamaya
okay but
it's off to the back diagonal
okay
so here this way
could be this way
you see
right it doesn't matter
but again
it's not this
you're fading
you're fading into the spiral that's
that's the footwork you want that's the
the uh Thai sabaki One how do I Fade
Into the spider
okay
um
then the second one you have is the
question is how far do I pay fake when
he hits zero
okay so in other words I'm here oh
that's not zero
okay
so fade until he hits zero
baby so this is
you could be around
Point what just shy of zero do you
understand
because you're going to do the next
phase so as it's coming in
instead of shoving them back that way he
you're going to do a kind of uh
political Edge on his head close the
garage on his head
you get that
so don't go here
and boom here
you're gonna go here there's his head
and around
see that
and that way he go he's he's not going
backwards yet you see he's not going
backwards but when I take his head
around then he's going backwards
then I can enter because he's going that
way and I'm going with him he goes that
way he has a you know
if I if he's still going forward when I
enter this is a clash and you're just
trying to overpower someone he has to be
going the other way so
without the entry you see okay
so when I enter don't enter where he's
falling
and not entering that
but you could
but we're doing the Xbox
okay so head goes one way
well there it is
okay
let's go okay so the question is Dakota
gash on the neck okay well let's make
sure we understand public right so he's
going in and I'm going here
oh
here
[Music]
thank you
right there right
right here see
the same thing here okay
there
later hi
yeah
is
hope
okay so what I'm really doing is taking
your grip your contact grip
and make it a new contact
here I lay it there it is right there do
you see and then turn it
pass your hand contact to your head
contact don't push here okay yield
I want you to touch your head
there it is I touch that and I adhere on
that it is on that
different right okay
cool and here
okay
thank you
so in this version of this technique
she's she's loading the eating
I I'm not here going
oh I'm not loading to Ada okay
so she's loading the Ed me she loaded it
you see
when if if when you watch me enter
is to attack her base
it's not to throw her head that's not to
throw her head
[Music]
I feel that so I'm here like this
sit down
easy
what what you're mistaking with the
contact on her head is that is your arm
fear push response it's just stuck to
our head
is following her head into the pot
I just wiped your nose okay
she loves DVD
I'm just staying here
I think I'm just saying with her
okay and so you if you watch
boom
look how much time this one takes
so yeah I have to be no patience
patience
patience means faith
patience means fake because
patience means waiting
for the positive future outcome you want
okay
it doesn't mean patience
okay so waiting
watch you guys you don't want to waste
you're right here and then you're like
[\h__\h] uh
clearly I'm not shoving her head down
otherwise I couldn't get to the back of
it and hold it up
okay
you just I'm maintaining contact because
that's where I was when I did the guys
okay
you can ask like the big why why am I
here why why do this right
even like we do the body conditioning
and strength is important right
strength is important but if you pay
attention to what I said it is important
for the training
so you can do the training
it's important in the fight that's true
but if you go well I'm here to learn how
to fight I
really how many fights do you how many
fights have you been in
zero what are you expecting the big
match tomorrow do you know
and those who got in a fight when's the
last time you got an actual fight
and what happens what do you what are
you imagining your 70 80
do you know what I mean
are you really gonna be
the champ at 80.
or maybe do you start going why am I
still such an [\h__\h] that I keep
getting in fights I'm 80 years old I
haven't [\h__\h] figured out how to just
get along with people
I mean these things what I mean is these
things cannot be
being here
you know I want to learn Aikido why why
you're gonna win the Aikido Olympics
do you know there's not one
here I think it's even crazier because
maybe you're like you know I want to
learn Aikido so I can get some Rank and
I can get some title and then you know I
can get people to start I can charge
them for seminars and I get the seminar
circuit going
yeah but we don't have that
that's not you're in the wrong place
we don't have that rank that title title
there's just what we're doing well what
are we doing and what is worth doing
it can't be
technical Artistry it can't be
and it can't be Marshall College it
can't be these are temporary things
worldly things meaningless States
but reconciling fear
that's a real thing
we use it's a Bruto so we use
the training of martial arts
and here's the one the part you don't
like we we use the training in martial
arts
to generate fear in you
so that you can reconcile fear
you can't work on what you don't put on
the workbench
do you understand
so we use that training
but the goal is not the martial arts
training
and so for that reason
it's wherever you're facing fear
that is the training
not the technique
or not just the technique
so sometimes it's
the oak is coming at you and you're
you're afraid you're afraid of failure
you're afraid of not getting it you're
afraid of how you're going to look to
people all that is [\h__\h] up that's why
we're working on it
all that stuff leads to your suffering
and to the generation of your suffering
it just keeps going
you are out of alignment
you're broken
but you don't just break yourself you
start breaking everything you want to
break everything
so that then we watch the fear in the
ukami
can you take the fall
do you pull out
do you decommit do you look for control
do you wish for a choreography please
let me throw myself
or can you just
reconcile fear and let the natural
course
the natural course way do its thing
but sometimes fears in all kinds of
other things
you get a correction from your teacher
and it sends you in a loop
you don't like it
that's a fear
why should it send you in a loop
is it not possible just to receive the
correction and put the information
without it going into this
childhood trauma
and um I don't feel good
I want you not to feel good
it is possible to receive a correction
purely
just like to receive the day and to
receive the sun coming up
undoubtedly there's people who dread the
sun coming up
but they're called vampires
they set the blood of other people
they're the undead they're dead
you know you watch for for centuries
people in the way have looked at animals
used them as
analogies I mean I've never seen my dog
go it's [\h__\h] Monday
whatever it is it's every day is Friday
to my dog
do you understand
he doesn't dread the sun coming up or
the sun going down
he eats what foods there and if he
doesn't want to eat it he doesn't eat it
he does not go
[\h__\h] I'm eating you [\h__\h] you hate me
he doesn't do it he just won't eat it
we're working on this technique work on
this technique get this correction
put that correction in
sometimes fear goes deeper than that
right because who cares if you get the
technique we only care about the
technique because of how fear ruins the
technique do you understand that that's
all we care about the technique
but in that same way it could be
a dojo
etiquette
right there's the on the dojo etiquette
there's a whole section and in that
section it has the Golden Rule
it reminds me of the law enforcement
policy that or or the penal code you you
learn to read the code and
and it will say like
a a is against the law B is against the
law C is against the law and then any
other letter that you might think of
that I didn't write that's also against
this code it's like a catch-all do you
get it
well the golden rule is the catch-all
it's a catch-all and fear reconciliation
in how you interrelate with other people
in other words you're not the same way
that resists
or the not yet forces do you see those
are all fear responses the same way you
relate to other people you're it
technically
the technical word is assholery you're
not allowed to be an [\h__\h] to anybody
in this dojo
do you understand
you can't curse Adam make faces at them
treat them in any other way
then I treat you
you can't do that you can't do that
you'll have to serve them
that's the same emptying of self
some of you I know for example
if one of you need help
and some of you would rather be in the
class than help them
do you see this
like if helping them conflicts with me
doing the class I'm gonna I'm gonna not
help I'm gonna do the class
again what are you gonna be
you're gonna win the Aikido Olympics is
that even what we're working on
could you do that
could I could I say
will you do this
and you just do it could I give you a
correction and you just do the
correction
could I say will you help this person
and you just help them
or would you have to go well then I
can't do my class
what's your class
do you get it what are you really
studying
but if I make you miss the class then
you feel robbed do you see
but where's the true teaching where is
the true teacher where is the true Desi
is it really in the class
it's not in the class who cares the [\h__\h]
about the techniques
it's this fear reconciliation it is this
this forfeiting this capacity to Forfeit
the self
can you do it
or is it always threatening to you
okay
sometimes you can do it
but I won't do it for you
I'll do it for you but I won't do it for
you
you outrank me so I'll do it for you
guys what the [\h__\h] where
what world are you in
I won't do it for you because you're my
husband
and you're not supposed to do this to me
you're not supposed to scare me
this is training
in the place where you're supposed to
reconcile fear
one I think he is supposed to scare you
here
and two I think the question is the same
question we've always asked hey why
don't you reconcile your fear why don't
you work on that
at the same time
if you feel
there's no way she's going to reconcile
fear
not here this technique is terrifying to
her
don't go
too bad [\h__\h]
you're in the wrong place time to get
[\h__\h] up
now you know what you do you go this
this is not the partner
where I work on these things
do you get that because you can feel
the stirring up of emotions
well to feel is feeling reconciled your
fear you
tell
when it's stirring up
she's gonna pull the life card on you
so you know we'll work on this
it's no different than when Taylor's
working out with the newer the newest
issue we have right now he's not not
slamming you is he slamming you he's not
slamming you it was so gentle
it was like here's a pillow
tuck you in
and a pinky
you see but he's yielding he's he's
doing the yield
he's doing the yin yield you see the yin
yield into the spiraling geometry
an important geometry if you watch the
old films of both Sensei that's all he
did this particular one okay but
if you watch our films where we're doing
anything goes and the guy's punching and
kicking you're gonna watch me do that
same Yin yield into the spiraling
geometry you see that because the next
thing the guy tries to do is turn really
sharp into where I'm at and that takes
him into the throws
so you just work on this do you say
if you watched on the video again I I
didn't I I have to teach
the reconciliation of fear to Leah
because she's in the dojo
so I have to bring fear to the technique
the fear we're using here is you're not
in control
it's a great fear it's a primal fear I'm
not in control
fear of falling is another Primal Fear
so I combined the two
you're coming forward do you see and you
you no matter what you want you somehow
going to you are going to load yourself
on my hip even though you don't want to
look I don't want to why why am I on
your hip
can you say that
right is again go back to the vampires
like the woman that invites the vampire
into the house or in the audience you're
like why'd you invite the vampire in the
house he can only go waiting if you
invite him
so I don't want to go on the hill [\h__\h]
I'm on the hip
facing
that's enough to generate the fear that
now lets her practice on acceptance
release of ego
but you've seen me lift and you've seen
me thrown Ronin and Taylor and this is
not was I chucking her no it was a very
very gentle throw you see
so I'm not going hey you're my Dashie
[\h__\h] off
do you get it this is the place to work
on food
right it's enough do what you can
got it all right
but in this way it's very confusion
because you do what you can and you do
what you can you don't say you don't do
that because I can't that's very woke
which is the opposite of confusion budo
has a confusion element to it you see so
you do
and you do
okay
but remember here remember
obviously to me fighting is important I
have a job I better know how to fight
right but it can't it's not what's
motivating me you can't motivate me
because even when I do the job what's
the whole point of the patrol strategy
do you see that
there's no way it's going to motivate me
here and there's no way uh technical
Artistry is going to motivate me
right it's not it's not going to happen
our videos would be better produced
we would do seminars instead of saying
we don't do seminars
if you want to come here you can come
here
and it wouldn't say such awful things
you can't say things people want to hear
this is very abrasive very abrasive
just like this is very abrasive right
not a very friendly talk
but it's true
it's authentic
but remember why we're here we're not
here for these for these worldly things
fighting and
technical
mastery
that's just crap
but reconciling fear that's gold
okay that's gold and remember the dojo
rule value what should be valued do not
value what should not be valued
okay